ti sto guardando anzi bentornati oggi
nuovo episodio marino sta guardando
fuori dalla finestra cosa facciate
episodio trova gli ingredienti slime a
grandissima richiesta berlino sta già
cercando gli ingredienti che si mandino
volgo di mozilla per grandissima
richiesta il personaggio tv ci sarà
annabelle la bambola impossessata
lasciate mi piace se sapete chi è la
bambola impossessate per lì non si è
messo a dormire
spero che mi aiuterà questa volta perché
sapete che le altre volte è stato un po
disastroso
lasciate un mi piace se volete un altro
episodio trova gli ingredienti slime se
questo video raggiunge i 20 mila mi
piace il prossimo personaggio sarà lo
slime ero curioso di vedere come sarà lo
slime è perché tipo 1 slime gigante
quindi mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace
avrò cinque possibilità come nelle altre
challenge
ok iniziamo subito la ricerca vedete
qualche ingrediente slime vediamo che
c'è nell'altra stanza che mi sembra
tutto molto tranquillo silenzioso
è sembrato tutti
ho visto un albero generali che mi
aspettava per fortuna non mi appresto
poi ha lasciato un biglietto vedremo
cosa c'e scritto bis me ok miss mi vuol
dire ti manco nono mirarchi dove i
marchi per vieste stato dietro il
disegno è una freccia riesco a capire
che disegno sia queste forse sono per le
scale riuscite a capire cosa si
riferisce queste cose se una porta a
porta e poi c'è qualcosa sopra la porta
potrebbe essere un indizio di dov'è il
il primo ingrediente slime vediamo
berlina secondo te dove guarda il
bigliettino riesci a capire dove non si
fa a berlino guarda bene e indicami dove
potrebbe essere marino sta votando la
storia
no ma non può essere questo è
completamente diverso bene allora però
forse potrebbe essere perché lì ci sono
le scale quella invece di essere una
porta potrebbe essere la porta armadio
per questo potrebbe essere il letto con
i pupazzi sopra la freccia stein di
quando verso le scale forse vuol dire
che devo stare lassù
proviamo ok spostato le piante
saliamo vediamo se c'è qualcosa qua qua
ci sono tutti i miei pupazzi ma non mi
sembra di vedere nessun ingrediente che
c'è marino don tu non puoi venire qua a
berlino insomma non può salire qua
eccola allora grazie berlino ho capito
che era qua sopra
facciamoci io scordiamoci
attento notarili guarda
ha fatto cadere un altro biglietto
ok è andata ok no andiamo dai sentiamo
abbiamo tra la colla dobbiamo vedere
cosa c'è scritto in quel biglietto
capito
e fammi center berlino lo posso sempre
se si stretto qui nelle scale dai
berlino
lo so che tu vorresti salire qua per
mangiarti tutti i pupazzi ma non puoi
[Musica]
dai come guardare con quello che non
posso farti salire qua ragazzi abbiamo
zona con da sta andando benissimo
vediamo cosa si è scritto nell'altro
biglietto che ha lasciato c'è scritto a
ciascun to play
voglio solo giocare ogni anno bello mi
ha preso per la prima volta quindi o
quattro possibilità adesso stranamente
ha lasciato il biglietto pensavo se lo
riportasse via comunque nel biglietto
sia scritto hijos monte play che vuol
dire voglio solo giocare ma io non
voglio giocare con lei
vediamo l'altro indizio allora speriamo
di riuscire a capirlo cos'è questa cosa
basta voci sono magari su pen
spero che l'abbia chiesa chiave come
credi berlino dove stai andando berlino
sto cercando gli ingredienti time ma non
ci ha preso la sopra di aiutarmi a
capire che cos'è questo tu sei
bravissimo interpretare questi disegnini
quindi vieni aiutami a capire allora
cerchiamo di capire
qua c'è una porta o forse un armadio
queste due cose non so se sono due
scatole qua c'è una tavolo se c'e un
tavolo poi la freccia tizia di quarta
qua sotto e quasi una faccia malefica
che sia
penso sia quella di anna bello e quindi
vuol dire che lei mi aspetta sotto
qualcosa
bene allora sarà molto facile trovare
questo soprattutto se lei mi sta
aspettando lì allora a me sembrano al
tavolo
potrebbe essere questo tavolo però non
c'è l'armadio sopra quel tavolo non c'è
proprio un armadio sopra aspetta forse
sì se ha voluto disegnare questo
scrivete nei commenti secondo voi cosa
ha voluto disegnare ma allora dovrebbe
essere qua sotto
non c'è niente devo guardare meglio
berlino via berlino
aiutami capire fini che cos'è questo
aiuto mi capire però non è rivolgerlo
dimmi solo dove indicandola come prima
l'ira smettila
c'è qualcosa sotto potete proprio questo
che voleva dire che perché quello è
l'armadio con un armadio e impacciate il
tavolo nel letto qua sotto
per fortuna non c'è una bella e mi
sembra non mi sembra che sia qua sotto
[Musica]
prendiamo la cena è sempre carte che
sono riuscito a trovarla nava si mangia
sempre puntare tutto ok abbiamo risolto
due indizi non mancano ancora altri ora
dobbiamo uscire da qua
gli altri si è mai meno giovato tu
rimani qua sicuro ok berlino vincere lo
ha detto a quanti entrano tutti sentito
no marino in mente non lavori che la
porta facciamolo bambina berlino no non
so quanti non per loro lentezza fini qua
la berlina da bello no berlino berlino
sta però da melo merlino
no sono deciso a tutto campo moderato e
come dicevo meteo per il indizio
proviamo a ricomporlo c'è scritto che
penso che voglia dire che vuol dire stai
attenta vediamo allora un altro
disegnino malefico diano belle che non
si capisce ma che cos'è capirlo dopo che
l'ha mangiato berlino
allora c'è anna bello da dietro che sta
guardando attraverso una finestra sta
guarendo un'altra ragazza attraverso una
finestra
quindi forse si può cercare in qualche
forse questa è la stessa annabelle bene
forse questo è uno specchio non è una
finestra
ok proviamo a cercare gli specchi
andiamo c'è un ospizio
eccolo è proprio di la spezia
si faccia tutto illuminato siamo pronti
siamo affatto o più di una ciotola
ragazzi sono riuscito a recuperare la
ciotola dovevo guardare meglio allo
specchio era proprio quello l'indizio di
guardare allo specchio perché c'era una
belle ma non l'ho interpretato bene
vabbè almeno ho trovato la ciotola
guardate mi mancano solo due cose il
bicarbonato e la soluzione per l'ente
evviva
il problema è che ho solamente tre vite
in più berlino e sto facendo rumore
vabbè andiamo in giro di stimolare
speriamo si gioca il biglietto senza
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa lì nel letto
siete c'è qualcosa di rosa
c'è scritto un working il che vuol dire
ti sto guardando
a chiudere l'affare che sta facendo mi
sta chiudendo a chiave
allora c'è disegnato una bella e
immagino ma è un po diversa non so avrà
un vestito rosso e ai capelli più corti
poi ci sono delle scale è una freccia
non ho idea di cosa voglia dire rimaste
nei commenti poi capite qual è l'indizio
per questo non capisco forse vuol dire
sopra le scale
proviamo a controllare sopra le scale di
là magari vuol dire che lei è lì sopra
le scale in questa posizione e
l'ingrediente sta dietro le scale ok
forse ho capito
dietro alle scale portiamo noi
[Musica]
basta di restare
c'è niente qualche 09 sbagliata
non c'è niente qua forse in queste scale
[Musica]
maledizione
svaniti xvi mi ha preso in un momento
solo due giorni adesso è sbagliato con
questo perché non è nessuna scalda tutte
le scale o controllate che cosa so fare
allora
però lei era lì in camera quindi forse
sta proteggendo qualcosa quindi proviamo
tornare molto piano
forse con tomismo bene ragazzi che cosa
vuol dire questo
ma
aspetta il momento sbaglio forse una
certa somiglianza tra questo e il mio
poster di joker cioè in realtà non
propria somiglianza perché una bella non
fa a disegnare per niente bene
16 anni sono bruttissimi su di te però
anche qui ci sono le scale e la freccia
dice di portare dietro le scale forse
sono queste le scale pd non scherza
visite risolvere il quartiere fb
abbiamo quasi tutto guardate abbiamo
quasi tutto manca solo il bicarbonato
quindi ora devo andare a cercare nobel
per l'ultimo biglietto
allora in camera
sicuramente qua piano
[Musica]
per forza prendere
c'è una presa all'ultimo biglietto
se fosse così iniziò allora c'è scritto
parli of light star che vuol dire hai
paura del buio un pochino sì ma che
cavolo è questo disegno non c'è scritto
niente
cioè non c'è disegnato niente guardate
c'è una freccia e c'è niente o niente
come faccio trovare qualcosa qua bene
serve al suo piano malefico sin
dall'inizio quindi il bicarbonato sempre
difficile però se lei dice hai paura del
buio e poi disegna tante strisce così
forse vuol dire che l'ultimo ingrediente
è proprio al buio
devo controllare nel posto più oscuro e
più al buio che c'è dove potrebbe essere
per questo è dentro un cassetto
[Musica]
cerchiamo il posto più al buio che c'è
qua non c'è più dubbio
[Musica]
qua c'è tantissima invece non può essere
qua dentro l'armadio effetti c'è un po
di buio dentro l'armadio ma non c'è
niente
guardate qua c'è tantissimo muoio io
sono qua anzi non si vede più niente
adesso
ecco perché il posto e posso più scuro
che c'è dentro l'armadio niente non
posso crederci sprechiamo sì perché mi
chiedo se sprechiamo c ma prima che
arrivi annabelle ai ragazzi ecco la foto
cosa mettere subito la colla di fare
silenzio strano che hanno belle è
sparita tra balletti e bicarbonato
finora tutto che sta facendo abbastanza
bene
vedete
ok ci mette un po ad atti perché ho
fatti
che ci mette così tanto tempo forse
brigate il climber che notte attive
e stato lì per lenti a specchio di
attenzione
no no è sempre più rizzi
[Musica]
così pronto
no aspetta è pronto eccolo qua anche
semplici cosa è pronto è che lo slide
c'è mancato un pelo
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi lo slime si è
formato all'ultimo secondo attiva
eccolo qua e uno slam rosa che si
illumina al buio
fate un mi piace se volete un altro
video trovo agli ingredienti lime e ora
vi lasciamo al 4 caselline su cui ti
caro per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione